you know the last two weeks I've gotten
so many messages of people asking me for
cash I need held you know I need you to
build me out because you don't know what
happened I bought my house put the whole
downpayment into this house and I cannot
believe what's going on right now I lost
the job I'm about to lose my house I'm
trying to foreclose the bank it's kind
of working with me they're trying to do
modification with me but again I need
somehow because I gotta pay the bills
everyone's texted me about cash now
here's the thing got to be thinking
about people are where they are in their
lives because they listen to someone's
advice and someone giving their advice
and you take it in that situation you
have two characters one is the
influencer the other is the influenced
you listen to the influencer who
influenced you to go do whatever you
want to do for example the influencer
says cash is trash and you say you know
what cash is trash let me go take all my
cash and just put in a real estate
because that's how I want to be a
millionaire the influencer says you know
real estates the American Dream and you
go by realistic cuz you think it's the
American Dream the influencer says you
know never study politics because it's a
waste of time so you don't study any of
that stuff and then you look at that
philosophy and you see if it works
during good and bad times and if a
philosophy only works during good times
is not a worthy philosophy to study if a
philosophy is only worthy during bad
times it's also not a good worthy
philosophy to study you need a
philosophy that's an evergreen
philosophy that can be tested in good
and bad times for example caches trash
what is the opposite of caches trash I
don't know a single person in America
today or in the world today that doesn't
wish they had more cache why because if
you had more cache you're not going to
be controlled by anywhere you're at your
job your boss the marketplace the
industry the three-point-two
unemployment applying for unemployment
two weeks ago 6.6 million this year
that's 10 million people apply for
unemployment in the month of March of
record by six six hundred fifty nine
thousand was a prior one why are they
needing this kind of search because they
don't have cash real estate is the
American Dream is real estate really the
American Dream or is it a great
marketing job because the real American
Dream is equity entrepreneurship owning
yourself something owning a piece of
something where it's not just putting
all your money into a home average real
estate return three point two percent
long-term am I really going to become
wealthy to do
through that was that really the right
way to go maybe the American Dream is
entrepreneurship entrepreneurship they
never study politics Plato once said
those who say never study politics will
be fooled by those who do meaning those
who say it's foolish to not study
politics will be governed by fools who
do that means if you don't study
politics other people that do study
politics who are fools will govern you
and they'll make decisions for you do
you want that to happen so maybe you are
to privately study politics maybe you
don't publicize it will you go study
politics and see what is really going on
what is the motive behind these guys
what are the most motive behind these
guys again the whole purpose of today's
message is the following sometimes it
requires a bad time to show up for you
and I to ask ourselves if our
philosophies work during good and bad
times sometimes during bad times you and
I have to ask ourselves who are the top
five people I listen to the most how are
their philosophies doing today
when the economy expands for a hundred
and twenty nine months in America you
know how easy it is to make money very
easy but when the economy isn't and it
drops 39% in a month
now which philosophies work because cash
is king today because entrepreneurship
is King today having his skill set is
King today knowing the politics and a
motivation behind politicians is King
today because you know no one can
control you
so write down whoever the influencer it
is that influences you and write down
their philosophies and see if it's
worked for you good and bad times if it
has keep studying those people if it's
not you may need to make some
adjustments to which influencers you
study too because by the way this is not
also pointing the fingers at the
influencers because the world is filled
with influencers this is to give you the
control of who you listen to she can't
say screw this person to hell with you
Pat no no no you're in charge no one's
forcing you to be influenced by anybody
you make that decisions make that
decision moving forward if your list is
a worthy list if it is continue if it's
not start eliminating some names just
like sometimes you got to eliminate
certain friends out of your life maybe
sometimes you get eliminate certain
influencers out of your life
you
[Music]